in terms of being a parent though Sarab
like you decided quite early this was
not for you yeah I don't like kids
no offense lovely but I'm getting enough
here yeah I was on holiday so we went on
two holidays abroad when I was a kid
when multi knows for and sphere when I
was 8 and when we were in Spain when I
was 8 I was my present I got on holiday
was a baby doll but it was like this it
was a giant having an inkling then like
what childbirth was they knew that it
came out of the part of a woman and I
thought no no on me that would ever
manager
think about the baby doll was that it
had it it had a dummy you took the dummy
out baby crying put the tummy back in
baby stop crying brilliant one this one
particular night you know people women
often think that the day they became a
woman was the day that their period
started not for me and this one night we
lost the dummy so the baby was
constantly crying I was bitten on the
nipple by a mosquito and it grew an
actual boob so I think that's the night
I became a woman
I was aired but I wore a bra and my baby
would not shut
[Applause]
[Music]